l'introduction de google en bourse cette
apparemment une question d'heures de
quelques jours tout au plus le moteur de
recherche le plus utilisé sur internet
est devenu leader en six ans seulement
une histoire atypique né dans un garage
de l'ingéniosité de deux étudiants en
informatique qui ne manque pas
d'originalité jean marc chollet
jean-pierre hackman ils viennent tout
juste de passer la trentaine et il surfe
sur le succès la trajectoire de sergei
brin et larry page est digne des success
story à l'américaine en 95 ils se
rencontrent sur le campus de
l'université stanford en californie
ils ont un même projet comment retrouver
une information à partir de l'énorme
masse de données disponibles sur le web
pour cela il créé google en 98 six ans
plus tard le moteur de recherche est
devenu une référence
contrairement à toutes les attentes ils
ont démontré qu'on pouvait inventer
quelque chose de nouveau dans le domaine
de la recherche sur internet c'est ce
qu'on appelle c'est un moteur de
recherche et à une époque où tout le
monde prétendait que les places étaient
déjà prises par les noms que tout le
monde connaissait à l'époque il ya où on
parlait à l'époque de like aux deux ex
ait eu en arrivant de lors de leurs
recherches à stanford deux jeunes
étudiants qu'elle n'aime pas fini leur
doctorat ont démontré que le marché
n'était pas du tout figé n'était pas du
tout terminé et qu'on pouvait inventer
quelque chose de nouveau
aujourd'hui l'entreprise de la silicon
valley emploie plus de 2000 personnes
dans le monde entier son entrée en
bourse est l'une des plus spectaculaires
de l'année en mettant leurs actions aux
enchères sur le net pour favoriser les
particuliers les deux ex étudiants ont
fait preuve d'une vision utopiste de
l'entreprise
il parle souvent de créer une
institution il parle pas tellement de
google comme une compagnie comme d'une
entreprise mais beaucoup d'une
institution il parle de transformer la
vie des gens de rendre la vie des
légendes plus facile de faciliter la
communication au niveau mondial les deux
golden boys ont dû cependant revoir
leurs ambitions à la baisse le prix
indicatif de l'action devrait s'établir
à 70 80 dollars contre 135 initialement
espérés la nouvelle star de l'internet
va devoir maintenant affronter yahoo et
microsoft qui prévoit de développer eux
aussi leurs moteurs de recherche